Joining me today is a contributor for
Canada's national post known here on the
Youtube, as my name is
Josephine Josephine. Matthias,
welcome to the Rubin [inaudible].
Thank you for having me.
I'm so excited to be here.
So your real name is Josephine.
My name is Josie can. It is.
I know why a lot of
people don't believe that.
I think it's like an alias isn't
really not that believable.
You say, my name is Josephine.
We're always getting punked online.
So they were curious.
Sorry.
That was gonna say,
I think they assume it's like Bong Queesha
or something. Joseph into really? Okay.
All right, well I'm, I'm really
super psyched that you're here.
We met about a month and a half ago in
Toronto after Jordan Peterson thing.
We got to chat a little bit.
Yeah.
And I've been a fan of what you're doing
for a while and I think you're actually
one of the few people on the
youtube making some sense.
Hello.
I feel special.
Thank you. So, so, uh,
let's just do a little bit about your
history first and then we're going to play
a clip from one of your videos in case
people haven't seen some of your stuff,
and then we're going to talk about all
sorts of political stuff because you are
a true political beasts. So you're
originally from Nigeria. Yes.
Lived there for what, eight or nine
years before you years to Canada.
So tell me about growing up in Nigeria.
Yeah.
Um,
I actually don't remember much about
growing up in Nigeria and my parents kind
of a closed me off to
what was really going on.
I lived in the gated community and um,
yeah,
I immigrated here when
I was nine years old.
My Dad actually first went
to Canada when I was too, uh,
he got here on a work visa,
worked his ass off for years,
for about seven years.
Actually.
I didn't even know who my dad was for
seven years. And then when he, you know,
got his visa and everything, he brought
my family over and yeah, now I'm in,
I'm in Canada. I mean, a great guy.
Yeah. So what did your dad do that Mike
was able to get a visa to go ahead.
Yeah, my dad was an accountant
and then when he got to Canada,
he went back to school and decided to do
nursing instead. And my mom's a teacher,
so that's, that's what they do. What
does your mom teach? She teaches,
she thought English in Nigeria and now
she kind of teaches us special ed kids
and stuff like that.
So she still loves teaching.
She obviously can't teach a nature and
person can't teach English in Canada. Um,
but yeah,
so she still loves teaching,
so I'm glad she's still kind of gets to
do that. But yeah. So my dad's accountant,
my dad,
my mom's a teacher.
Yeah.
Do your parents tell you anything about
the political situation or anything at
the time when you were growing up, even
if you don't have great memories of it?
Uh, not necessarily. My parents
were not really that political. Um,
I think we became more political
when we came to Canada. And I mean,
politics in Nigeria is just, it's
completely corrupt. And there,
there was no such thing as politics.
It's all just money. And, um,
is when I came to Canada is when they
start to get a little bit more political
and uh,
I don't know,
I think religion and strict parents
kinda create conservatism in a way.
So they're very, very conservative.
Uh, so I, I had grew up about, um,
around that, but they didn't
really name it as conservatism.
It was just strict and religious and had
all these rules that basically apply to
conservatism in the way. Yeah.
Yeah. So then you get to Canada,
you're not even 10 years old. And what
was that like to be in a new country?
So weird.
I mean 16 degrees outside
and I was freezing.
It's why is it so cold? And there's people
wearing t shirts. I did not understand.
Uh,
I remember like driving from the airport,
I think it's piercing airport
and we all stopped and was like,
why are we stopping? And they're
like, oh, it's a red light. I'm like,
what does that mean? Don't you just go
into this? Everyone has figured it out.
My Dad's like, there's order here.
I was like, oh, okay. And snow.
Snow is the best one.
I think I spent like half an hour just
like touching it and like what is this?
And My,
uh,
elementary school teachers or middle
school teachers had to tell me to get back
inside. I'll freeze. But
yeah, it was, it was really,
it was surreal as a culture shock.
So it was mostly a weather related
weather whether an order. Exactly.
It's basically it.
Whether an order,
so when you say you grew up in like
a in a religious atmosphere where,
what was that like?
Um,
my parents were just super religious and
they hoped I'd be also as religious as
them.
Unfortunately I'm not.
But I think that kind of comes with
age and also living in, I don't know,
a different country.
Nigeria, it's easier, easier.
The majority of people are religious. Um,
but yeah, they, they are still a very,
very, very Catholic. I'm
Protestant. Yeah. So, yeah.
Yeah. So, okay. So now you're
in Canada, you're a kid,
you're making a good life for yourself.
When did you get interested in politics?
Ooh, I got interested in politics. Uh,
while I'm taking political science and
studying political science in school
right now. And, um, I was also
president of the debate club.
I was just interested in like
this scores and discussing things.
I was interested in people's ideas
and different ideas and reasoning,
the reason for things.
Um,
but I also think my political views
were really shaped by me immigrating to
Canada and we lived in the inner cities.
I'm not sure if you've ever heard
of Jane and finch by any chance.
It's kind of like a south side
of Chicago lights. Like it's not,
it's obviously not as bad. Um, but it's an
inner city majority black, um, you know,
poor neighborhoods. I lived there for
most of my Canadian life actually.
And then from there I moved to a more
higher income neighborhood and having to
experience that.
So it was really cool,
kind of seeing like the culture there
and then get another culture shock and
move somewhere else. So it's
like I've experienced, you know,
Nigeria in the inner city in Canada
and then a much more, you know,
well off neighborhood. So, which would you
say is the best out of those three? Uh,
Nigeria, no, the wall up
neighborhood. But yeah,
living in like the um,
inner cities really it shaped my views
because now when I look back I was like,
oh,
that makes sense.
You are a product of your environment
and a lot of people that, you know,
I think about two,
three of my friends made it out of there.
The majority of them are,
you know,
pregnants are single parents now they're
in the system and it's unfortunate and
weird to see that happen.
And my parents being extremely strict
and they gave me a curfew at like 5:00 PM
every day. I wasn't allowed
to, you know, have boyfriends,
which I guess I was young, I probably
shouldn't have. Um, but they were really,
really strict and I
hated them at that time,
but I didn't understand why they didn't
me to go out and play with people and
now I get it because I would have ended
up like a lot of the people that are
still there right now. Um, and then, yeah,
moving to like the much
better neighborhood.
I realized that while
there is a difference,
there is a cultural difference I guess.
But yeah,
when I've watched a ton of your
videos I thought all right,
I sensed that she basically is a liberal,
why kind of liberal.
But I think you are probably
some conservative leanings
perhaps or at least have
an understanding. I think that's
what you're laying out here.
You have an understanding
of that line of thinking.
I you consider yourself a classical
liberal. I don't want to push you,
but I'd like to hear you say it but,
but what do you actually consider
your views to be? Um, okay. Here.
I know everyone says they
don't like putting labels,
but I absolutely hate labels because
like I have some conservative ideas,
I have some liberal ideas, I have
some classical liberal ideas. Um,
I have some progressive ideas,
socialist ideas.
Um, but I guess I just see a look at
things from issue to issue, but I am,
you know, primarily liberal,
but I'm fiscally conservative.
So that's kind of where I lean I guess.
So the route I think of of
your ideas, he's sort of
individualism. Yeah, for sure.
Yeah. Yeah. You want to throw to
a clip? Yes, let's do it. Alright.
Let's get people to know you
and your natural environment.
West has also been tweeting about the
lack of freedom of thought in America and
the backlash about whether blacks
can be allowed to be Republicans.
Sure is helping prove his point. But Black
Americans, contrary to popular belief,
can hold widely diverse and opposing
opinions and political issues.
Maybe Connie as a Republican, I mean,
he's ever referred to himself as such,
of course. But he said something about
Trump that wasn't severely negative,
so he suddenly the Black Paul Ryan.
But even if he is so what?
In fact,
a 2012 study by Vincent Hutchens and Kim
Jefferson using data from the American
national election studies found that
45% of black Americans identify as
conservatives. Despite this, however,
the Democratic Party typically received
85 to 95% of the black American vote.
The tendency of black Americans to vote
Democrat allows the Dempsey believe that
they have a strong hold on the
black American vote. In fact,
back in 2016 when Kanye West announced
he would run for president in 2020 the
democratic Party's official Twitter
account immediately assumed.
He meant he'd be running for them
responding. Welcome to the race, Mr. West.
Glad to have you.
If only the Dems had Ron Kanye in 2016
better candidate than she who shall not
be named to be.
All right.
So I think I picked that one because
it's a great example of what you do and
there's,
there's information and facts and it's
kind of light to and find and all that
good stuff. Now, first off though,
as a black Canadian talking about
black Americans, that's kind of racist,
wouldn't you say?
Yeah,
I think I've gotten a lot of
comments of people saying like,
he don't understand what it's like to
be black in America. And it's like,
oh my gosh,
thought I can have the same discussions
about race relations in America.
It's just a little scaled down in,
in the Canadian context.
And I think a lot of
Canadians try to project,
I guess I American issues on Canadians
as well. So, um, but yeah, I know,
I do get that criticism,
which is annoying.
We should all be allowed to
talk about whatever we want.
You are black in America right now?
Yes, I am. I know it's awful. I mean,
sign down like 10 times. People are
yelling the n word at me. I mean, I just,
I feel so unsafe. Well that's
why we create a safe space. Okay.
So I want to about that video though,
because the numbers that you laid out
there actually kind of incredible and
something that we obviously had been
talking about lately related to Kanye and
Candace and the rest of it.
Foot,
45% of black Americans consider themselves
conservative yet at 85 to 95% of our
voting Democrat. That is a
massive disconnect. So, so
what do you make of that?
Yeah,
I think it's just,
there's an idea that the Democratic Party
is the best one for black Americans.
It's the one that's going
to help black Americans.
And although they are conservative and
you know, in the true sense of the word,
they aren't necessarily Republican. They
don't believe in the Republican Party.
Um, but it is, it is very interesting.
I mean no one group or identity bolts
the same way as black Americans do.
So there is some kind of,
I guess,
story that's being told to them
that this is the way to do it.
This is the way to go. And
I don't think, you know,
the Republican party
per se is the way to go.
And I don't think the Democratic Party,
in fact,
I think both parties are just garbage at
this point. Um, but yeah, I think it's,
it's a little odd that the
majority 95% vote one single way,
but yet they're still conservative in a
sense. Um, but yeah, I just think it's,
it's uh,
it's a leftover ideas.
Like they just need to kind of
start to refigure things up.
But first we probably have to start with,
you know,
changing up the government and changing
up the party systems and I try to find
who to vote for instead of just
picking Democrat or Republican.
Do you think this was more of a good
sell job by the Democrats who are a bad
cell drive by the Republicans?
Cause when you look at all this,
the cities especially where
it's the worst for black people,
they're always democrat run cities
for decade after decade after decade.
Yet black people still in extremely
high numbers keep voting Democrats.
So that's obviously a great
sell job, right? Yeah.
Somebody is doing some serious PR work
on. Yeah. Oh yeah, definitely. And um,
I think it's also the
Republicans as well on,
I think Black Democrats make it feel like
the Republicans are against the black
Americans and the demo on the
Republicans make it feel like, you know,
the black Americans are against
Republicans. Like it's just,
I think both sides are not
necessarily trying to help.
They're just trying to
pander to their own side.
But it is interesting that you've been
voting Democrat for so long and things
are not getting better. It's like, oh,
maybe I should start voting a different
way or maybe I should start criticizing
the Democratic Party.
I think that's actually the biggest
thing is it's not picking a side.
It's criticizing what they're doing
wrong. It's criticizing, you know,
this didn't work.
Let's try something else.
Instead of just saying we
need Democrat and that's it.
This is what's going to happen,
but it's clearly not not working.
Let's try to figure out what policy
changes we need instead of trying to pick
like, you know, Democrat or
Republican. Sorry, I keep saying that.
I've never got to know. I'm with you.
I'm with you. So I know you're not,
you're not a huge proponent
of the sort of Candace
Kanye training in general,
but the fact that that
conversation is happening now,
the fact that you made that video,
you view that all as positive, right?
Oh yeah, no, for sure.
I think Connie really allowed a lot of
people to think for a second and try to,
you know, investigate some
more information, try to
figure out what their real,
why they hold certain ideas.
I think that was the biggest
thing and it was really exciting.
It's like scroll through Facebook and
see people that are not normally engaging
in politics.
Now.
Actually that might be scary because it's
like the majority of people are saying
you don't know what they're doing. But
yeah, I'd rather have them some way.
Exactly. I'd rather have them
involved. And the thing is,
I think as much as I, um,
you know,
dislike Ken is politics.
I do think that it opened
a lot of people's minds in
the sense that it allowed
them to investigate more.
And that's the most important thing
because then you're just stuck in the echo
chamber. Connie broke that. A lot of
people, all they see is, you know,
beyond say and Chrissy Tiegen and all
these celebrities that are all just
talking about the far
left, you know, super.
I hate saying social justice for you
over Super Social Justice Warrior talking
points. So Kanye broke that and
show them the other side. Um,
unfortunately I think, uh,
you know, because Candace is
kind of harsh and you know,
I think it's harder for people to connect
with her that are already sold down
the drain of the far
left. And unfortunately we
might have to cuddle them,
fill the Neil, come on, come
to the other side. It's okay.
Let me explain things to you.
So do you view that as just
like a personality trait?
Because that's what's interesting to me.
Like people used to say to me
all the time, well, uh, you know,
when you have milo on like Milo's
creating chaos and out of chaos,
hopefully my feeling was if I brought
Milo on that out of the chaos that he
creates, that some people would hear some
good ideas in a more calm, relaxed way,
and then they joined me on
the adventure that I'm on.
And I think there's proof in that pudding.
Yeah,
I think you're kind of a little bit more
like where I think you see a little bit
of the chaos that cannabis is creating
and you want people to understand the
ideas behind them.
Yeah. That's, that's the
thing is that, you know, when
Candice says one thing, like,
um, stop the victim
mentality for example. Um,
I think black Americans that are stuck
in like the far left echo chamber just
sees it as like, excuse me, like what
are you trying to save a little blot?
So it's like they needs either
she explains it further,
which obviously she doesn't have to do.
I mean she can do whatever she wants,
but I think she needs to break it down
a little more cause saying get off the
plantation,
the victim hood,
it's harder for people that all
they've ever heard is white privilege.
White people suck, blah, blah, blah.
It's harder for them to kind of understand
where she's coming from because if
you do break it down, it makes a lot of
sense. But if it's just thrown like that,
then it's harder for them to figure
it out. What they can do. The,
I keep like pointing here
like the Liberals are these
people over here. Yeah. Um,
so we just need to kind of
break it down and figure
you think maybe you need both.
Like in any movement,
like if you just look at the black
rights movement that Malcolm x who is
different than Martin Luther King.
And even the way comedians talk about
things differently because we talk about
things differently than Dick Gregory, then
Chappelle and Chris Rock. We just need
people. People just get affected by
different things. Yeah. Shock value works.
I mean it gets people, it wakes people
up. It allows them to kind of, you know,
be more aware of what's going on. I
totally, I do think we need both of them.
We need people to say, you know,
shut up, you're being annoying.
And we also need people to say,
here's why you're being annoying.
We most certainly need both. Um, but yeah,
I think she, what she does is awesome.
She has such a great platform and there
are also other people that are doing the
same thing,
but in a more kind of calmer,
I'm not saying she's like crazy
or anything. Um, yeah, she's just,
she's a tough girl and it's
a lot of SJWs or snowflakes.
So I might goes out any
direction. Um, not necessarily.
I mean I think we've,
I have d under like we've talked
over dms on Twitter before. Um,
and this was after the whole Blair
white debate and that was wise guys,
guys, guys. Yeah. Uh, no I was just um, at
reaching out to her and asking her like,
Hey, what's going on? Like
I don't, cause she was,
I think closing everyone off that were
criticizing her and I didn't want to
openly criticize her and I wanted
to go directly to the source. Um,
but we left off on like a good
notes. Yeah. Yeah. All right,
well I'll put it out here.
Why do we have a Jay z Kanye moment and
you both can come on the show sometime.
Oh yeah, let's talk it out. Yeah,
you're going to be like guys guys,
please guide if I'm a glutton
for punishment. Exactly.
So when I was doing a
little research on you,
one of the things that I thought
was most interesting is that,
so you have a twin sister and part of
your awakening was related to a paper that
she was writing in college. Yeah.
So can you tell me about that?
Cause it's pretty fascinating. Yeah. So
my sister is not into politics at all.
She is studying marketing
and she decided to take,
she goes to various university,
one of the biggest far left
universities in Canada.
And um, he took a sociology
course that was her fault.
I made called how society works.
I think it was the title of the
course or is what bothered me.
Cause if the course was feminism studies,
if the course was,
you know how women are oppressed and yeah,
sure,
but this is how society
works and you know,
in your assignment they had to talk about,
I know some societal issue and
discuss it and analyze it or whatever.
And she wanted to talk about the weight
or I actually encouraged her, I'm like,
you should talk about the wage gap and
you know how it's false and you know how
it's misinterpreted and all of that.
And you were setting her up.
I was setting her up a little,
I wanted to test it out,
but I didn't know it would, the professor
would, you know, respond that way. Um,
but yeah,
I told her to write about the wage gap
so she just sent like a short thesis and
said like, here's what I want to
talk about. I'm going to use studies,
blah blah blah.
Let me know.
And the professor like her response is
a meme like I hope I could let you guys
can like put it up or something.
It's like the reality is patriarchy
do not use business sources.
They blame women and it's like period.
The reality is patriarchy do not.
They blame women and like you
know the screenshot on this,
you can say sure we're going to throw
down. Totally. Yeah. I was reading it.
I was like okay, this is fake, right?
This is, this is definitely fake. No,
she basically shut it down and she
said your premise is completely,
and it was one of the most absurd emails
ever and use only feminist sources and
in the assignment details,
the list of sources they can't use
was dictionary.com the encyclopedia.
You couldn't use the
government of Canada website.
You couldn't use statistic Canada,
Statistics Canada.
How like how does that even make sense?
How are you going to explain how society
works and the only source you have is
feminist studies and you know, as
Peterson has mentioned this so many times,
they're not sighted.
It's just within this little group.
These aren't real textbooks. Uh, but
yeah, it just, it blew my mind and I was,
I'm so excited that she sat back cause I
was like this is exactly what is wrong.
So okay, so your sister
gets this response. What was
her response? Was she like,
Oh look what you did to me? No, yes.
She was upset at me and she thought I
was wrong and I have to sit her down and
say, girl, let me explain it to you.
Here is what is actually happening.
By the end of that conversation
she's like, oh my gosh, I've been,
every class I go to, I've been lied to.
They are lying to me every single day.
And it, it's, it's, it's so messed up
and I think it's, this isn't teaching,
this is imposing your political ideas
on students because if it's teaching,
you teach it objectively,
you show them the facts and
let your students come up
with their own conclusions.
This is not teaching. She's trying to
tell them how to think. And you know, I,
I did some research on her actually,
and she's the highest paid woman
in her person, in her department.
She makes more money than the male
counterparts. What are you talking about?
So I'm sure there's a reason.
Yeah, exactly. But it's like,
there's obviously reasons
for it. She probably works
more hours. She's, you know,
doing all these other things and that's
how you can explain the wage gap.
So it was just interesting to me that
why like why are they doing this?
Why are you lying to your
students or isn't the point
of education for you? Like,
or essays or assignments.
Like you're supposed to come to
your own conclusions by using facts.
We have the facts. What's wrong with it?
She just didn't want those facts. It,
it blew my mind. But that was right.
Well they're often not for facts. Yeah.
Facts that they lie. Yeah. What
happened with the paper? Oh she,
she's like, okay, this is like
too much for me and my sister.
And she ended up just doing some other
like topic and try to pander to what the
professor wanted to get a good mark. And
that is my advice to a lot of students.
It's like, just suck it up. I mean
if you are already in this class,
it's not worth getting a bad
mark over. Um, however, sorry.
The great thing about it was I got a
ton of messages from students from her
class started to explain all the other
things that this teacher is engaging it
and how awful it is. And that made me
happy cause they said, you know what,
next week I'm going to speak up and
I'm going to tell her she's wrong.
And I was like, yes, yes, but be
prepared. Don't just say she's wrong.
So it's interesting. So I talk about this
when I do college, uh, speeches. Yeah.
Two years ago or so. I used to say
what you said about get the grade,
like suck it up and get the green because
hopefully you know if you want to move
to Grad school or get a good job after
or whatever, and I, I've turned on that.
But really you're the one 80 on that
because to me it's like we live in a time
where people can be on youtube
and expose these things,
share the emails out on social media.
Periscope while you're in classes,
the teacher is telling you that
you're an evil white racism.
Many videos of my teachers.
Just the worst thing.
But that's been so empowering for you.
So that's why I'm not for telling kids
can students not to do that. But I,
I understand the line of thinking and
I guess it depends on the person or
anything. It's still can challenge
your professor while he's, you know,
just teaching.
I met more for assignments.
The assignments says explain why women
are oppressed. Like just do it. That's it.
Like if you, you're probably going to
fail if you say women are not oppressed,
but if the teacher is actually teaching,
then yes please.
That is the best time
because you catch them at it.
And I love watching them squirm.
I love watching them just kind
of look around and it's like, oh,
there's a black woman asking me to tell,
you know,
tell her why she's oppressed
and my white professor,
please tell me what rights you have
did I don't have in Toronto, Canada.
And it's like, well, you know,
there is white privilege.
It's like, oh my gosh, stop.
It's enough. Do you feel bizarrely
empowered because of that? Now, I mean,
someone who's clear on their
political thoughts and you don't,
you're not a victim nor want
to be a victim or anything
or he's immigrant status
or blah, blah, blah. Do
you feel very empowered?
Like almost like your teachers can't
push back on you in a weird way because
they're caught in their own
guilt cycle? Yeah, no, for sure.
And it's also funny because, um, you
know, I am the, I'm an immigrant,
I am black and I'm a woman.
It's like I just have to be,
I guess Muslim and I'm
all the impressions. Um,
so it's really difficult
for them or anything. Yeah.
I got to limit to emulate every
oppression there is. Um, but yeah,
no, it, it's, it's,
it's kind of funny to see how they can't
challenge me because a lot of their
arguments, it is based on
lived experiences. This
is what black people face.
And I'm talking about
the Canadian context.
I think Canadian social racial relations
is a little bit different than the
states than here in the states. Sorry.
Um, but yeah, me being like a black woman,
it's, it's very difficult for
them. Like they can't give me any,
they have to give me a legit argument
because the only argument is, well,
black people feel that way. I don't.
So what is your argument? Um, but yeah,
I mean in, in a sense it does kind of
make me feel empowered because it's,
it's funny to watch them score.
Do you feel that you've had
an undue influence? You know,
I suspect in a positive way
on some of your classmates,
because I'm imagining they're probably
learning as much from you in some ways.
Oh yeah. More than they're learning from
some of these professors. Yeah, for sure.
Um,
it's actually fun.
There are some classes I would have where
a professor would say something absurd
and like there's a student that I know
knows me from Youtube and he'll look at
me and I'm like,
I'm not saying anything and I know raise
your hand and they'll talk and they'll
want me to like chime in and I'm like,
I don't want to do this in every class.
I'm not going to be challenging
my professors. Um, but yeah,
I really liked the fact that I've
encouraged so many students, you know,
step up and actually speak up and say what
they believe in. And um, yeah, it was,
it just really,
it's really interesting.
There was a course where one of
the textbooks, I forgot, dammit,
this is why school sucks cause like you
forget everything literally, instantly.
Um,
but one of the students that how it was
problematic and before we just kind of
brush it off and then another
student rose their hand and said,
why is it problematic? And it looks
at me. I was like, Oh God. But yeah,
I really liked that. I've encouraged
people to speak up and you know,
state what they believe and do more
research and not just listen to everything
your professor is saying,
not just listen to anything I'm saying.
Do more research and investigate
and try to find, you know,
let's get closer to the
truth is basically it.
Do you think students want to
be smarter than this stuff?
They're being spoon fed?
Because I definitely do. And
when I go to these schools,
I see such a thirst for knowledge and
honesty and facts and an exhaustion with
this nonsense.
But if you listen to the way the media
talks either about millennials or
whatever, it's like they're the spoiled
entitled generation on that same,
I'm not saying that a lot of them
aren't, but I, I genuinely think that,
that most people, especially young
people, they want real answers,
not just like easy dribble.
No, for sure. And, um, I think a lot of
this has to do with the student unions.
And again,
I'm talking,
I'm obviously more familiar with the
Canadian context of this. Um, but the,
you know, major schools,
University of Toronto,
York University and viruses university.
I go to University of Toronto,
run by black lives matter, Ryerson black
lives matter and feminist, uh, York.
University of black lives matter.
I mean,
individuals that are part
of the black lives matter.
Original organizations are the presidents,
vice president and all that
of the student union. And, um,
I was a president of the debate
club for about three years,
the first three years of my
schooling. And I was like, you know,
what would be really exciting to
have a debate on race, racial issues?
I would love to. I don't care if
I'm on this side, on the other side,
that would be such a good thing cause
all we're ever being fed is raised.
Every corner there's some poster about
being black and UFT, which by the way,
people just realize like
during the Trump election,
we've been here for three years.
No one complained and all of a sudden
Trump is elected. It's hard to be black.
Come on. Um, but yeah, I,
I went to go talk to the school presidents
and I said I would love to have this
event, all of that. They shut me down.
They said anyone that goes in the other
side on the opposite side is, you know,
trying to question the humanity of
black people. How dare they try it.
And I'm sitting there like, I will be
the one, like what are you talking about?
But yeah, they, they canceled it
and shut it down, which is so sad.
It was so excited for that.
So
it's interesting.
I know you've been pretty critical of
black lives matter and I want to get into
that a little bit.
But the moment for me that I realized
it had morphed into something that I no
longer felt was positive because at the
beginning I did think it was basically a,
a positive movement.
Yeah.
Or a grass roots movement that
was making some sense and,
and addressing some important issues.
But the moment I realized that it jumped,
the shark was in Toronto actually
at the Toronto Pride Parade.
When they stopped the parade,
they literally stopped the parade from
marching to demand that the organizers of
the gay pride parade or
another oppressed group, uh,
submit to their demands.
Their demands were that they were going
to focus on these issues. And I thought,
wow, what a perfect example of everything
that's wrong with identity politics,
with the oppression,
Olympics, the whole thing.
And then subsequently saw a lot more
of that style of thinking happening
throughout black lives matter.
But was that moment for you as someone
that's from a Rondo? We met in Toronto,
um, is that, was that a seminal moment
for you? Yeah, for sure. I mean, I,
I absolutely hate black lives matter.
Toronto.
I can't say much for many of the
other black lives matter chapters.
What black lives matter.
Toronto is extremely toxic and divisive
and I think it's mainly because I,
we were getting so much better in terms
of racial relations and people were
getting along and there wasn't really,
I mean, I'm speaking for myself.
It wasn't really that many
racism or racist acts happening,
but all of a sudden they
erupt and they say, you know,
black people feel uncomfortable
during pride because of the police.
When again happens during
the Trump presidency,
it's like all of a sudden you're
starting to feel oppressed.
And it blew my mind stopping the
pride parade. I was so confused.
They stopped it for like an hour asking
for demands that the police be band.
And it's like being a gay police officer,
isn't that an oppression?
And then they say, okay, but you can go
without your uniform. Are you kidding me?
No, that's not the point. The
point is there was a stigma
against being, you know,
a police officer and gay being gay.
How dare you take that away from them.
And there were a lot of proposals,
by the way,
during the pride parade with officers
and their uniform. That's beautiful.
Like what are you, are you really going
to try to marriage proposals? Yeah,
it's married. Yeah. Sorry. It's marriage
proposals. Yeah. It was like, oh my God,
this is such a great thing.
But no, no, no. Now they,
they've actually been banned.
They didn't,
they're not coming to the pride I think
for the next like five years or so. Um,
but that actually was not the
reason why I started to hate BLM.
Do you remember the Jordan Peterson
free speech event in Toronto? Oh,
yeah. Uh, so he teaches at
University of Toronto. My school,
and this is actually when I
started making videos. Um,
it was because during the,
the event he,
this was his first public event after
making the series of videos and um,
black lives matter was there, you
know, just there are two sides I guess.
And I wasn't really picking a side.
It was also my very first protest.
I was just there to observe.
I was very confused as to why
people were yelling at each other.
What was going on? Oh, I
should have just gotten home.
No. Yeah. So I, I, you know,
I observed the whole thing and
it was pretty peaceful there.
People of color went up there and
we're seeing things like, you know,
I don't feel oppressed. This is one of
the greatest countries in the world,
especially Toronto. Like this is so
diverse. It's everyone loves each,
everyone's nice to each other. Um,
you know, the black lives matter,
we're calling them coons,
they're calling up sellouts,
they're yelling all these things.
And I immediately knew who the aggressors,
where I immediately knew who,
which side I did not want to be on.
I wasn't picking sides,
but it was like, Oh God,
I stayed til the very end until the
last person left because this was again
first protest. I was like
excited and talking to everyone.
I got home and there are articles that
are posted by the school newspaper,
by Toronto Star about, you know, black
people were, you know, called the n word.
They were harassed. Someone
brought dogs, someone brought dot.
I was actually standing next
to the person with the dogs.
So when apparently brought
dogs to chase off the block,
black people complete lies. And that
opened my eyes to like the media bias.
That didn't happen, not even close
to being happening to happen.
So it blew my mind that
they would lie about that.
And then I personally messaged a,
the leader of black lives matter instead,
I am disappointed girl. I was there
like why are you doing this? Um,
and then I decided to start making videos
cause I said clearly there in getting
the wrong information, the
school, literally things.
Jordan Peterson was this Nazi that came
and said I hate black people and women
and transgenders and all about, um,
so I just thought like, you know what,
if no one's going to do it, I should do
it. And then I started making videos,
which was weird cause I had to go to
school the next day and then deal with
these people.
Yeah. But do you know what you, you put
your ass on the line and yeah, paid off.
Wait. So did, when you a DM, the
black lives matter president,
did she respond to you?
Yeah. She responded to me saying,
I'm, I'm going to screenshot this, uh,
to use against you in the future.
Why don't you say it to my face?
I still have it saved cause I'm like,
I'm going to save this for the rest
of my life. Yeah. The, the president,
like the CO founder of black lives
matter Toronto said she's going to,
I should say it to her face
and she's going to use this
against me in the future.
Meanwhile, all I said was, I was
there. This is very inappropriate.
Why are you telling lies or making
black people feel like, you know,
this is what actually happened.
You're making students feel like that's
why students feel like they're being
oppressed because you're telling them,
sorry,
what do you know?
What do you think these people,
and I don't mean just black lives
matter in this case, but like this,
this type of person at a university,
whether it's from gender studies
or whatever it is, you know,
with all the identity politics stuff,
what do you think they
actually want in the end?
Like if they were to get what they want,
what is that?
That's what I don't understand is that
the are obviously fakes because if they
truly care about black liberation,
there are policies that you could point
to that you can probably fix and help
the black community and,
and Canada,
one of the things was a carding and that
was actually immediately carding was
gone. I'm in Toronto, Ontario. I'm not
sure either the province or the city. Um,
but that's the one thing where
I was like, okay, random stops.
I think that's something
that you should be, you know,
stopped and it's done in inner city
neighborhoods and blah, blah blah.
Apart from that it's like, okay, what else
do you want? They want black professors.
They want police out of pride.
That's not helping black people.
That's not changing their social
economic status. So what do you,
what is your goal? I really don't
understand cause it's, you don't care.
I don't want to say, I mean I do
care. I don't want to say like I'm,
I have all the solutions but
I can tell you what to do.
But they are telling
people false solutions.
You're telling them that we need all black
professors to teach black people. Um,
but I don't know what their, what their
goal is. I don't know if I is money,
I guess. I really don't get
it. I don't get it seriously.
Okay.